hey this is presh tollwacker here's a
fun set of puzzles make each equation
True by inserting parentheses you're
allowed to insert parentheses between
any two characters
I'll read each equation
the first equation
4 plus 8 times 5 minus three times five
is equal to 45.
the second equation
3 times 10 minus two divided by 4 plus 4
is equal to 10.
the third equation 16 minus three times
four plus seven minus 1 squared is equal
to forty
the fourth and final equation
5 times 8 plus 8 divided by 6 minus
twelve times two is equal to 24.
I think everyone who suggested these
puzzles to me
pause the video if you like to give this
problem a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve these
problems
[Music]
there are three reasons I think these
puzzles are excellent one is that they
help build number sense this is a
concept that was there when I was in
school you should know the different
magnitudes of numbers and how numbers
interact with each other it's not just
about doing calculations but it's about
understanding say if you get the bill at
a restaurant does it even make sense
what they're charging you
another reason these puzzles are nice is
because they promote experimentation
mathematics is not just about memorizing
different formulas and plugging in the
numbers it's actually about getting
numbers getting different concepts and
seeing how they relate to each other and
sometimes that will involve
experimentation where you try one thing
it doesn't work you try another thing it
doesn't work you try another thing it
doesn't work eventually you will get to
the correct answer but there is a
struggle to mathematics
these puzzles are also a good reminder
about the order of operations which
could be remembered by the acronym
PEMDAS which refers to parentheses
exponents multiplication division and
addition subtraction if you have two
operators of the same precedence
evaluate them from left to right you
could also remember this as bodmas where
parentheses has the analog brackets and
exponents has the analog orders
I've also heard it's known as bidmas
where orders has the analog indices
so however you remember it is fine you
don't always have to work in this exact
order but if you do work in this order
you will get the correct answer
so let's work on puzzle one
let's just evaluate the expression as
written
so 8 times 5 is equal to forty three
times five is equal to 15.
so we have 4 plus 40 minus 15 which
equals 29. we need this equation to be
equal to 45 so we are too low we need to
increase the value
so how do we do that
well one thing we can do is we have four
plus eight times five so let's just
group the four and the 8 so we do that
first
so now 4 plus 8 is equal to 12. 12 times
5 is equal to sixty then we need to
subtract 3 times 5 3 times 5 is 15. so
we have 60 minus 15 which is equal to
45.
so we found the answer
now let's move to puzzle two
three times ten minus 2 divided by 4
plus 4 is equal to 10. let's just
evaluate the expression as written 3
times 10 is equal to 30. 2 divided by 4
is 0.5
so we have 30 minus 0.5 plus 4 which
equals 33.5 this expression is too large
we need to decrease its value
so to decrease the value
one way is we can group the first
Expression 3 times 10 minus two so we're
grouping what we're going to be dividing
by four
now 3 times 10 is equal to 30 we
subtract 2 to get 28
28 divided by 4 is equal to 7 then we
have 7 plus 4 which is equal to 11. so
we are still slightly too large we need
to decrease the value of this expression
so what can we do here
let's try another thing let's just group
this 10 minus 2. this will decrease it
ever so slightly so 10 minus 2 is equal
to eight three times eight is equal to
24. 24 divided by 4 is equal to 6 and
now 6 plus 4 is equal to ten so this is
the correct answer
now let's go to the third puzzle
we're going to have to start being
creative these are getting harder
so if we just evaluate this expression
what do we get
we get 16 minus 12 plus 7 minus 1 and
that's equal to 10. so we're too small
we need to increase this value
so one experiment we can try is we can
group this 16 minus 3. so 60 minus 3 is
13 we multiply by 4 to get 52.
52 plus 7 minus 1 squared this will be
52 plus 7 minus 1 and that's equal to 58
so now we need to decrease the value of
this expression
so after some experimentation here's
what you need to do
remove the grouping between 16 minus 3
and then add a grouping between seven
minus one
so now here's what the expression
becomes
seven minus 1 is equal to six then six
squared is equal to 36.
then 3 times 4 is equal to 12. so we
have 16 minus 12 plus 36 and that is
equal to 40. so that is the correct
answer to puzzle number three
now on to the final puzzle like the
other problems let's just evaluate this
expression as written so we have a
starting point
this will work out to be 40 plus 8 over
6 minus 24 which equals 17 and 1 3.
so we need to increase the value but we
also need to get the value to be an
integer so there are many things wrong
with this expression I'm not going to go
through all the different experiments
you can run I'm just going to explain
what the solution is
so one thing we'll do is we'll change
the denominator we'll make it 6 minus 12
times 2.
now this is going to be a negative
number we don't want that so now what we
need to do is split the one and the 2 of
The Twelve
so we apply parentheses here so we have
6 minus 1 multiplied by 2 times 2.
finally we will group 5 times 8 plus 8
in the numerator
so let's see how this all works out
5 times 8 is 40 we add 8 to get 48.
that's the numerator now what's the
denominator 2 times 2 is equal to 4 we
multiply that by one that will still be
four then six minus 4 is equal to two
so we end up with 48 divided by 2 is
equal to 24 and that is the answer to
this puzzle
how many did you solve
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
[Music]